[Música]
la desesperanza de la población libanesa
Es evidente la duración de la crisis
económica está acabando con cualquier
esperanza de mejora a corto plazo la
situación no era tan grave ni siquiera
en tiempos de guerra y la sensación de
angustia se extiende incluso a los más
resilientes Ibrahim tiene que vivir con
menos de 30 euros al mes a pesar de su
trabajo en este barco la primera pasada
intentó cruzar el océano para llegar a
Italia
mi madre dijo que si teníamos la
oportunidad de irnos lo haríamos
ella escuchó que en cualquier país
europeo nos tratarán como seres humanos
sin dinero pasaporte ni visado él y
cinco miembros de su familia intentaron
el viaje en este barco sobrecargado
Ibrahim dice que la embarcación acabó
hundiéndose tras un intento de las
autoridades libanesas de detenerla desde
entonces sus dos hermanas han sido dadas
por desaparecidas pero a pesar de ello
él está decidido a intentarlo de nuevo
no funciona la primera vez Pero seguiré
intentándolo hasta que lo consiga porque
aquí en el Líbano ni siquiera tenemos
dinero suficiente para pagar la atención
médica huir del Líbano ya sea de manera
ilegal o no es cada vez más frecuente
pues muchos residentes ya no pueden
continuar viviendo en la pobreza aquí en
trípoli la segunda ciudad más importante
del país muchos dicen que esta crisis
económica es única en su género pues ha
sido una de las peores del mundo desde
1850 según el Banco Mundial con una
inflación en porcentajes de tres cifras
por tercer año consecutivo 8 de cada
diez habitantes
ahora por debajo del umbral de pobreza
incluso la factura de la luz supera mi
sueldo también tengo que alimentar a mi
familia almuerzo pero ya no ceno
recibo dinero de mis hermanos que viven
en el extranjero Y así es como llego a
fin de mes
esta crisis comenzó en 2019 tras años de
corrupción y mala gestión por parte del
Estado según las Naciones Unidas el
marco económico nacional y el sector
bancario cayeron como un castillo de
naipes los bancos se han convertido en
blanco habitual de la indignación de la
población Incluso el personal de
seguridad que protege a los bancos tiene
dificultades para ocultar su frustración
hacia las autoridades cuando se les
pregunta si creen que el gobierno les ha
robado cree como los manifestantes que
el gobierno los robó sí pienso eso pero
todo lo que podemos hacer es hablar
gritar
todo lo que estamos viviendo los ahorros
de la gente ya casi no valen nada y lo
poco que queda aún no se puede retirar
libremente en efectivo la libre libanesa
ha sido devaluada recientemente en un
90% por el Banco Central
debido a esto este empleado militar ha
visto como sus salarios se reducía
drásticamente
y salario mensual es de 2,5 millones de
libras libanesas antes de la crisis eran
1900 euros
pero ahora por todo lo que ha hecho el
gobierno solo vale 220 euros
el Líbano está Sobreviviendo gracias a
la ayuda humanitaria y a las donaciones
extranjeras esta solidaridad es ahora
extremadamente importante para esta
profesora de beirut como la compañía
Nacional de Electricidad está al borde
del colapso no hay ascensor en su
edificio después de las cuatro de la
tarde Así que sube a pie hasta su
apartamento en el décimo piso elen
representa a esta clase media libanesa
recién en empobrecida que ahora tiene
que aceptar la ayuda de un vecino para
alimentar a su familia
es la primera vez en mi vida que acepto
ayuda
al volver de la escuela esta profesora
da clases particulares en su casa a
estos jóvenes
completa este ejercicio por favor
ella aceptó un segundo empleo al igual
que su marido pero los ingresos de su
hogar han disminuido un 60% en los
últimos cuatro años incluso con todo lo
que hacemos lo único que podemos
permitirnos es comer solo eso
para poder comer nada más solíamos vivir
una vida agradable
ahora que trabaja 60 horas a la semana
esta madre ve mucho menos a sus hijos su
hijo menor ha comprendido que es la
única forma de hacer frente a la crisis
trabaja duro para que podamos tener una
vida sana y todo lo que deseamos crees
que es valiente por hacer todo eso sí se
sacrifica
con un sistema político paralizado sin
presidente en el cargo desde octubre y
sin llegar a un acuerdo sobre los
términos de las nuevas elecciones no
parece que la crisis del Líbano vaya a
llegar a su fin pronto